hi there i'm reza aslan and i'm rayne
wilson and
i love you
are you talking to me
i am talking
to everyone including you yes you dude i
love you
but what does that even mean i have no
idea that's a great question let's dive
in
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
so
you and i both know that we're supposed
to love our enemies right rain is that i
mean that's what they say in the bible
that's what it tells us in the bible and
all of them love our enemies i'm sure
it's sure it's in the quran too and the
bhagavad gita the big one yeah it's a
big one
i guess the question is to what end
like what i'm sorry like
what are we loving our enemies four
we have some different points of view on
this reza i mean i truly believe that
love is the maximum
force for change in the world that it's
uh
it's a it's a power that we need to draw
on that it's it's specific that it
leads us to action
and uh we are we are lost without it i
think in this day and age of everyone
shouting at each other outraged at each
other there's certainly a lot to be
outraged about but you know what
shouting at each other is just not going
to get it done it's just not i mean you
can think it is let's let's try it for
10 years and see how that works out well
see we're actually not as far off as you
think it is i too think that love
is a profound tool of social change i do
think that it is a magical quality and
that you can
really um you know you can you can do
profound things with it
but
who deserves that love
you know
i mean yes can love be a force of social
transformation yes
do you get that social transformation
by loving your enemy i don't know i
don't think that's the case i mean i
think shouldn't you fight your enemy if
your enemy is trying to destroy you do
you really think that if you love them
that somehow that'll change your enemy
that'll make things better i mean let's
really think about that i think that's a
false dichotomy i think you can't say
like the choices are to love them or to
fight them the choice is i think to love
them
to understand that they can change and
that they can redeem themselves and to
absolutely disagree with what it is that
they're doing and let them know in no
uncertain terms and fight for change
while loving everyone on that path you
know what we need what do we need we
need someone
to come between us okay and and help us
sort this thing out and it turns out we
have exactly that guess who could that
be her name is valley core
she is a religious scholar a lawyer a
civil rights activist she's done
everything from working at guantanamo
bay and in super max prisons to clerking
with the senate judiciary committee and
her newest thing is that she started
this project called revolutionary love
and i guess what she says is the point
of it is to reclaim love as a force for
social change
she calls it um a compass and a
framework for life and perhaps maybe
even a way to save lives and maybe she
can she can help us figure this out uh
let's let's find out
[Music]
my name is valerie core i'm a civil
rights activist and a movement lawyer
and the founder of the revolutionary
love project i like i like the idea of a
revolutionary love what what is that
exactly
i like the idea that a lawyer could
somehow be involved in revolutionary
love please explain
well let me be clear i was the person in
the audience who anytime someone said
all you need is love i would cringe and
roll my eyes
so i think i'm doing right now
yes i i was you so let me invite you
into what i've discovered so
revolutionary love i believe is the call
of our times
it is the choice to enter into labor for
others for opponents and for ourselves
that's how i'm defining it but i came to
it sort of the long and hard way so i
was a civil rights activist for 15 years
i went from
campaign to campaign from community to
community i really became an activist in
the wake of september 11th
um when my uncle was murdered
the man i called uncle bobier sodi was
the first person murdered in a hate
crime after 9 11.
as a family friend yeah so he was
confused uh to be a muslim yes he was a
turban sick father who was killed by
someone who called himself a patriot
and so i devoted my life i became part
of a generation of sikh and muslim
advocates who
were organizing around the problem of
hate and hate crimes and i just thought
if we just filed enough lawsuits if we
just made enough films if we launched
enough campaigns then we can make the
nation safer for the next generation
how'd that work out
fast forward
white nationalists claim this moment as
this presidency is our great awakening
hate crimes are skyrocketing once again
at levels that exceed what we saw in the
aftermath of 9 11. but now i'm no longer
a college kid i'm i'm a mother and i was
putting my son to sleep and realizing
that
for all of our advocacy that we could
not make the nation safer for my son or
his generation that he's actually
growing up in a nation more dangerous
for him than it was for me or for my
grandfather when he arrived 100 years
ago to this country
do you really believe that too true that
that your son is in a more perilous
uh position with hatred around him than
your grandfather was 100 years ago
arriving in america that's what the data
tells us that sick and muslim americans
are five times more likely to be targets
of hate violence than we were before 9
11. i can't think of a time in which
i'm the first generation
uh in my family in america but like if
my father or my grandfather were here i
can't imagine a time in which they would
have had to sit
in a classroom and stare up at a
photograph of a president
who with every word is threatening their
very lives which is what my children do
they sit in the classroom
and they pledge allegiance to a flag
that's next to
the photo of a man who a hates them
and b
uh threatens their very lives on a daily
basis how do you feel about trump
so reza so your great challenge then is
to love trump to love him for his
humanity let's get let's get to that no
but i i interrupted uh at the beginning
you were talking post 9 11 a lot of
activism thought we could change the
world and then there's a shift there
there was a shift coming what was that
it was my existential crisis okay it was
like what is the meaning of my life so
at this point i'm at stanford law i'm
working on net neutrality that's my
latest issue
i'm watching you know another sick
grandfather is almost beaten to death in
my hometown where my family is lit for a
hundred years and i open up my tool kit
i can i can make a film i could organize
i can file a lawsuit and i'm just
paralyzed i can't do anything
um because my toolkit is useless i
thought so i left my job
i spent months sort of in seclusion
reading and writing and thinking and i
thought back on my life and i thought
back on my grandfather's stories i
thought back about my on my community
struggles and i asked myself like what
is the one thing that has actually
created social change for the people i
work with what's the actual thing that
has created change in my own life in my
own moments of crisis and
it was never like the film or the
lawsuit or the campaign those things
were necessary elements but it all came
down to a totally surprising question
is love a practice here
are people responding
in the wake of
injustice and massacre with love are
they receiving love are they fighting
even their opponents with love are they
loving themselves
in the absence of love no change was
possible only with love as a kind of
demanding rigorous practice was i seeing
change and i thought revolutionary love
you know if love is more than a rush of
feeling if love is a kind of labor then
love can be taught love can be modeled
love can be practiced what might happen
if we could equip people to practice
love as a force for social justice both
in their lives and in our movement so
that is why i left and created the
revolutionary love project with this
message which brings me here is
revolutionary love essentially are you
defining it as
love that spurs action also can we
define our terms because love is let's
do it love's a tough word you know like
i love my wife i also love people love
puppies you love the oakland raiders i
love this podcast
so let's start just with love so when we
talk about love we tend to think about
it as a rush of feeling it's an ecstatic
emotion that overcomes us
and that's because we use romantic love
as our primary reference point now
falling love is a beautiful life-giving
human experience it's delicious it's
delirious it's like falling into a jar
of honey the problem is is that it's
something that happens to us that we
have very little agency over it and so
we're taught that love is the most
important thing on earth and yet we have
little control over when and how it
happens
now if we expand that definition of love
then we see a different picture and this
was my aha moment
10 months ago my daughter was born
and she was placed on my chest
and
you know i'm sobbing and i'm shaking and
i'm feeling the rush of oxytocin just
flooding my body right this is falling
in love
in the meantime my mother is opening up
her bag and getting ready to feed me
feeding her baby as i'm feeding mine
like the doll and the jewel are out and
i'm looking at my mother and i'm like
oh
my mother has never stopped laboring for
me from my birth to my children's birth
like she already knows what i'm still
learning which is that love is more than
a russia feeling
love is sweet labor you know it is
fierce it is demanding it is imperfect
it is bloody it is a choice that we make
over and over and over again
it's like all of the feelings right
you're fathers like joy is the gift of
love
grief is the price of love
anger is the force that protects that
which is loved
so if we're thinking about love as sweet
labor
and that's the kind of love that we see
in our most
most life-giving relationships
what might it mean to love beyond what
is prescribed
what might it mean to love others who
don't look like us who we don't know
what might it mean to practice love for
even our opponents i know which is hard
which we'll get to
what might it mean to love ourselves who
we too often neglect
and i believe that this kind of robust
like love as an ethic
this call to love has been on the lips
of spiritual teachers and geniuses for
thousands of years right from buddha to
jesus to muhammad to guru nanak i mean
guru nanak said if you want to play the
game of love with me step forth with
your head on your hand this is not easy
can you let us know who that person is
that you're just referring to for our
listeners guru nanak is the founder of
the sikh faith s-i-k-h which is the
faith tradition that i grew up in
great
so
can you put this revolutionary love in
context of other forms of social justice
and kind of place it in history because
obviously
i think about martin luther king as
someone who
inspired by gandhi
put
this kind of love into practice i mean
people that were
but in both with gandhi and king people
that were oppressing them
killing their you know just oppressing
their people in every way filled with
hate and rancor um and
not only hating them
but
i keep saying oppressing over and over
again but like like [ __ ] them the
[ __ ] up yeah and yet calling for love
yeah uh toward those people so are you
just continuing their work or is it
different can you put it in context it's
a continuation and an evolution so king
gandhi mandela they built entire
non-violent movements rooted in this
ethic of love love as a wellspring for
courage that people didn't know they had
right solidarity that they built wasn't
based on duty or obligation it was based
rooted in the choice to love one another
to love even their oppressors right so
what might it mean to reclaim love now
for this generation for this time for
this political climate we are in and of
that tradition but we're doing it
differently
first we're reclaiming love
through a feminist lens and so we're
taking seriously the physiology of the
body we're taking seriously love for
oneself we're not collapsing the public
and private realm so we're using a lot
of feminist work womanist work to
reclaim love and we're doing it in such
a way that is it's a source from which
everyone can drink so it doesn't depend
on a belief in a particular religion or
a particular god okay wait you you threw
in feminists here yeah so are you saying
that the previous love is like of the
patriarchy or something like that and so
this is a new kind of love based more on
feminine forms are you saying it's
so gandhi king mandela they talked a lot
about how to love others and how to love
our opponents they didn't talk a lot
about how to love ourselves this is the
feminist intervention this is bell hooks
and audrey lord who said caring for
myself is not a form of self-indulgence
it's a form of political warfare and so
we're taking seriously the fact that too
often have women of color like
they the movement has happened on their
backs or over their dead bodies so what
might it mean not to think of suffering
as a form of service what might it mean
to talk about a form a practice of love
that takes seriously the liberation of
our bodies of our
of the communities who are suffering
even as we're laboring for justice
that's the intervention
[Music]
folks good health starts with good
habits and quip makes it easy by
delivering all the oral care essentials
you need to care for your mouth the quip
electric toothbrush is loved by over 7
million mouths and has timed sonic
vibrations they have 30 second pulses to
guide a dentist's recommended 2-minute
clean it's got a lightweight and sleek
design both for adults and kids there's
no wires no bulky charger to weigh you
down and on top of your brushing folks
you can upgrade your quip with a new
smart motor to
a track and improve your brushing with
the free quip app and earn amazing
rewards i love that idea brush your
teeth get rewards free refills products
target gift cards and more with stylish
and affordable electric brushes starting
at just 25
you won't be paying through the teeth
for better oral health good one i really
like the mouthwash by the way very very
refreshing and folks if you go
to get quip dot com slash milkshake
right now you'll get your first refill
free that's your first refill free at
get quip dot com slash milkshake that's
spelled g-e-t
q-u-i-p
dot com slash milkshake quip the good
habits company it's never too early to
start gift shopping for the holidays
especially because today you can save
big on a gift they'll use every day i'm
talking about raycon wireless earbuds i
got myself a pair of these earbuds a
couple of months ago
they were so great they were so
fantastic and then i let my niece borrow
them and i've never seen them again
but i keep seeing like pictures of her
on social media with these raycon
little earbuds in her ears and i'm like
those are mine i want them back rain you
want me to uh take care of this you want
me to get those raycons back from your
knees because um i know people the thing
about these things they've got the
seamless bluetooth pairing they're this
comfortable noise isolating fit you can
start listening right away and you can
keep listening for hours the audio
quality is amazing the best of any
headphones that i've ever used it's
basically comparable to like what you
would get from other premium brands
except that recon starts at half the
price my friend raycon offers eight
hours of playtime and a 32-hour battery
life there's also a built-in mic and you
can take calls on your earbuds at the
press of a button so this holiday season
get them something they can use for
calls or music for work or play at home
or on the go
or just you know what just pick up a
pair for yourself and your niece
so go to buy raycon.com
milkshake today to unlock exclusive
deals up to twenty percent off your
recon order but hurry this offer is
available for a limited time only and
you don't wanna miss it that's by raycon
dot com slash milkshake to unlock up to
twenty percent off your ray cons by
raycon.com
milkshake
[Music]
so how do we put this love and action
the way that these civil rights heroes
of ours
did we created a team of researchers
from the fields of ethics education
conflict resolution and neuroscience i
really kind of it was awesome
and which one of them is hawkeye
you could probably just tell him to stay
home
he's fine you don't we don't really need
him
keep going
um is we wanted to roll up our sleeves
and get serious about like well how do
people practice love like if love is
labor then how do we practice it and i
thought okay we begin with empathy or we
begin with compassion or respect
i was completely floored by
the discovery that the primary act
in choosing to love another person
is wonder
can i look up on your face
and see you as a sister as a brother
can i wonder about your story can i
wonder about you such that you are as
vast and complex and endless as i am to
myself
can i look upon you and say you are part
of me that i do not yet know
and when we do that we expand the circle
of who counts as one of us
and if we see another as one of us we're
more likely to grieve with them we're
more likely to fight for them when
they're in harm's way
brain imaging studies show us that we
divide the world between us and them all
of the time consciously and
unconsciously we can't undo it and
demagogues win when they so successfully
shut down our capacity to wonder that
they make entire groups of people vermin
or foreigners or terrorists or them
but to reclaim our capacity to wonder is
to resist that is to expand that circle
and that's where solidarity can be built
so our primary practice and how to love
others is to wonder about them to grieve
with them and to fight for them when
they're in harm's way
we can talk about opponents and
ourselves when you're ready well
just to follow up on that for one second
so yes you expand the circle of who is
us
but there are still people who are them
yes so what about them
i would say
can you convince reza to take this love
to donald trump
over the course of this podcast no
the answer that question is no
because i'm i'm very curious to about
this issue of
them and i'm and i'm and this is aren't
you making donald trump of them he's he
is them he is for sure them yeah and not
just him
but every different everyone who
supports his policy then the you know
governor of the racist governor of
mississippi or alabama during the civil
rights movement or the or the racist you
know british governors of india during
that no direction he is as much them as
possible for me them is actually a
pretty easy category
if you
dehumanize
an other if you
strip
another humanizing another just by
saying no because i don't i don't loathe
donald trump
because he's an orange american
there are a lot of orange americans that
i i think are worthy of love like my
uncle i loathe him because
he is a despicable human being who
exudes uh moral rot and evil
that he puts his work and effort
into
demeaning and dehumanizing other people
because of the way they look or because
of their socioeconomic status or because
of their their background
i loathe him
because
the world would literally be better if
he weren't in it
that's a that's different
right that that definition of them i
think
is very difficult for me to burst
through i
i think i spend a good part of my life
in the mlk camp but the older i get
the more
i move from his camp to malcolm x's camp
it's okay to have them
donald trump is my opponent too
white nativist and in fact anyone who
has voted for him is my opponent too so
my dad voted for trump is he your
opponent unfortunately in this moment
yes
and so are members of my family my
family my my most of my in-laws how how
are they your opponent they're not my
enemy they are my opponent because they
have supported policies that directly go
against my existence and my son's future
and so what does it mean to practice
love
for them
um
it's to affirm their humanity
and that's the baseline so here's what
i've discovered
that there are no such thing as monsters
in this world there are only people who
are wounded
who because of their own insecurity
their own sense of threat their greed or
their blindness
cast the vote or pass the policy or pull
the trigger that is aimed at us
but if we start to wonder even about
them and listen to their stories beneath
the slogans and sound bites we hear that
they're frail human beings
we hear how their participation and our
oppression comes at a cost right it cuts
them off from their own capacity to love
so what does it mean to love them the
practice that we've developed is called
tend the wound and the very first step
in that is
is rage
people tend to think that rage is the
opposite of love but in fact audrey lord
tells us that rage carries vital
information
that rage to find safe containers for
our own rage make it so that we don't
suppress our rage and hurt ourselves or
let it explode in violence toward others
so tending our own wound is the first
step tending to our rage and for some of
us we need to stay there
for those of us for whom it is safe the
next step is to listen to listen to
what's at stake to for our opponents and
we listen not to change their minds to
prove that we're right we listen in
order to gain critical information about
what it is that allows them to hurt us
what policies allow them authorize them
to hurt us what cultural norms allow
them to hurt us and in gaining that
information like loving our opponents is
not just moral reza for me it's
strategic it is pragmatic it is how i
gain the information to reimagine is the
final step reimagine the conditions that
continue to allow them to hurt me
[Music]
so here's how i love donald trump okay
here's how i lived okay because
here's here's what i think truly like
the first stage in any kind of spiritual
journey is oh we're all connected oh
look at that we're all cells we're all
molecules we're all we are all breathing
we're all struggling we've all suffered
um
i imagine the the the horrors of donald
trump's upbringing what would it be like
to be raised by fred trump but then if
you go to next level i go
i'm not just connected i i am donald
trump we are all one we are all
actually
completely and totally unified and i see
in myself a lot of trump i see
narcissism i see vanity i see wanting to
be right a lot so i see these qualities
in myself kind of bloated in in another
person and that allows me
to go i'm i'm not only connected to
donald trump i am donald trump there's
trump in me there's reign and trump
there's beauty in life and breath uh in
all of us that might sound a little airy
fairy hippy-dippy but i truly believe
that for humanity to progress forward
instead of yelling at each other on
twitter and trying to shame people on
twitter which is essentially kind of the
extent of most people's social activism
these days that we have to
build something that
recognizes the beautiful divinity
that makes us all literally the same
you are practicing revolutionary love
and thank you yes can i get a
certificate no because
because um
it's also
your
if i may be so bold
um privilege as a white person that
allows you to wonder about him and
connect with him in that particular way
if you're a person of color if you're if
you're
a muslim or a sikh or an immigrant right
now where you have a boot on your neck
and you cannot breathe it is not our job
to look up and wonder about the person
who is trying to kill us
right what kind of father did he have
yeah i mean but somebody else can do
that work sometimes i can do that
sometimes but most of the time martin
luther king did that work and gandhi did
as well
but again they
i i don't i don't boots on their necks
but to and i agree with you i understand
that my white privilege gives me a
certain kind of remove i haven't seen
friends like
unjustly like shot by cops you know for
their skin color i haven't seen my
relatives put in cages you know i have
so i i haven't seen my uncle shot
because he was brown you know of course
i i totally get that but isn't it a
challenge really for all of us
that's why we're connected you and i and
that's we're part of a movement right
you can do that wondering work when i
can't when all i can do is breathe to
survive to get through the next day when
i need a place for my room i'm a little
confused because you said that you that
was that wondering was the next phase so
you're saying you can't do the wandering
work
there are certain opponents for whom i
can wonder and listen to
right and i got to the point after 15
years where i could do that with my
uncle's murderer i couldn't do it a year
after
but i'm thank god there was somebody in
the prison to do that because it helped
him heal it helped him learn how to
apologize eventually right
so
we all have different roles in different
moments and as long as this president is
our oppressor right now in chief
like i need you and others to do that
work with his supporters and with him
and i need others to stand up for me um
to wonder about me and to grieve with me
and to fight for me and i need to learn
how to breathe and push through the pain
so that i can keep surviving
in other words the framework is so
robust revolutionary love is so robust
that everybody has a role in any
different time and as long as i'm not
saying reign don't do that because he's
a monster then i'm practicing
revolutionary love too i'm saying you
are part of me reigning you can do what
i can't do right now but for me the idea
of like well what would it take to to
love trump that's a nonsensical question
i think that there is a very clear
moral absolute when it comes to
individuals who are driven
by the need to dehumanize others to
remove others humanities there is no
gray area there for me it is black and
white
if that's who you are
there is no room for you in this
conversation there is no effort or
energy that i'm going to expand in any
way shape or form in trying to
understand you let alone reach out for
you
you
have have uh you deny the most basic
rule of the game
so
there's a difference i think sometimes
that gets confused as anyone who
disagrees with me or anyone who is my
opponent is outside the game on the
contrary this isn't how i feel about all
trump voters on the contrary this isn't
how i feel about trump voters who you
know want lower taxes or stronger you
know immigrant borders that's not that's
not what i'm referring to here but
if you accept
the trump ideology
right which is that if you're brown or
you're black
or you're gay you're less than
for me the moral the moral clarity there
is
quite uh
clear so
this could be a much longer conversation
but then you don't believe in redemption
because i think that love leads to
redemption so
i think the key for me reza is that
everybody has a different role
right
yeah everyone has a different like i i
the
the boot is on my throat like when i
anyone asking me to love this president
i mean i i get triggered right and then
i remember like
oh what is revolutionary love right now
it's tending to my own wound and giving
them permission to do the listening
right it's not my role that everybody
has a different place and every and
different role at any given time and
that's why i think revolutionary love
can only be practiced in community i see
it as an orientation to life that is
both political and personal it's almost
like a compass like what do i need what
do i need now i need i need love for
ourselves like communities of color who
are in harm's way right now they they
need we need um to to survive
[Music]
okay you know what rain every single
time we do one of these brooklyn and ads
i say i woke up in brooklyn in sheetz uh
this morning and i think at a certain
point people are thinking reza do you
wash your sheets and the answer is yes
but i am obsessed with my brook linen
sheets i put them on every single time
instead of putting on any other sheets
they are
so comfortable look you can't put a
price on comfort right
you just can't and you know what brook
linen's biggest sale of the year is
right around the corner folks wait so
then you can put a price on comfort
brook limbins love the pun brooklyn
brooklyn's entire site of supersoft
seriously cozy essentials is going on
sale this weekend brooklyn was created
to bring dreamy comfort to every corner
of your space at prices so affordable
they may make you pinch yourself
brooklyn's comfort game is unmatched and
their lineup keeps getting better they
got five star sheets that were just the
start now they got this collection of
cozy must-haves that includes things
like dream it decor and also they now
have these newly launched slippers
brooklyn and his slippers brooklyn has
slippers will you get me those for the
holiday because i think that you
probably can get a a deal on those i
actually wasn't planning on buying you a
gift but okay i'll think about it so
don't miss out folks brook linen's
biggest sale of the year is here
are you listening to this after the sale
you can still save visit brooklyn.com
and use promo code milkshake for 20 off
with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's b r o o k l i n e n dot
com
promo code
milkshake
i'm not meaning this insulting at all
but i'm hearing a lot of great phrases
we need to do this in community
etc
but how do you put this into meat and
potatoes practice on the street as a as
a means of actually affecting social
change i'm not interested in creating a
revolutionary love movement
i'm interested in seeding the existing
movements with the concept and practices
of revolutionary love so when i see
young activists claiming black lives
matter when i see indigenous elders at
standing rock when i see the thousands
of people at airports standing for
muslim and sick and hindu and americans
in the wake of hate violence from the
wake of these policies i want to and
look how many people are already burned
out
right how many people are opting out how
many people are tired and numb and when
we are tired or numb we retreat into
whatever privilege we have right how do
we stay pushing into the fire i see my
role and the work of this project as to
give people tools to keep pushing into
the fire and so we do this on the ground
right we do this we curate hundreds of
dialogues across the country we work
with the places like the women's march
and um and other coalitions to give
people mass mobilizations we are
creating a curriculum for university and
college campuses we are trying to stage
a meaningful intervention in the 2020
election season but here's what i want
to say like social change happens i
believe in the course of 25 year cycles
and in the next 25 years the united
states will be calm for the first time
since colonization
the number of people of color will
exceed the number of white people so we
are at a crossroads right will we like
will we birth a nation that has never
been like multi-racial multi-faith
multicultural where power is shared
where we strive to protect the dignity
of every person right or will we
continue to descend into kind of a kind
of civil war
you know
a a power struggle with people who want
to return america to a past where a
certain class of white people hold
cultural economic political dominion but
and when we think of of climate change
then the question becomes global right
the storms are coming the seas are
rising humanity itself is in transition
right will we marshal the skill and
solidarity and vision to solve this
problem together or will we perish
the greatest existential crisis
that we are facing isn't political it's
not economic
um it's global
so
explain to our listeners
how
a strategy of revolutionary love
can help affect the kinds of radical
climate um
changes that we need to enact in order
to keep from you know all dying
in the next two three decades so love
for others love for opponents and love
for ourselves
love for others
it means that we have to love and care
enough about those millions of people
who are mostly black and brown people
around the globe who will be most
affected by the climate change that's
upon us
we must see them as
mothers and fathers and children like
our own
and we must be able to have the capacity
to grieve with them
and then to fight for them so wonder
grieve and fight are the core practices
under loving others what does it mean to
fight it means everyone has a role that
everyone has a sword is it your pen is
it your artist brush is it your scalpel
is it your pocketbook the idea is that
everybody has a role in this fight i
think too many people are giving in to
despair into helplessness but each of us
has a voice in some particular way so
that's how we love others
love for opponents i think it's
important to protect rage there's a lot
to be angry about the corporations and
the governments and the previous
generations that has allowed this to
happen so we protect capacity for rage
and we value our rage and then we listen
to what's at stake for our opponents and
right now it's greed
and it's a very short-term way to
understand the world and it's not enough
of us being at the table and so then the
final practice is reimagine how do we
reimagine the condition so the rest of
us who want to save the world have a
seat at the table it begins with our
elections and so i i think that that's
how we love for all of our opponents for
too too long in my in my world as an
activist any time i've gone after bad
actors i've put away police officers
i've taken down mayors i mean we've
actually done the work um we never
really changed very much right any time
we went out after policies systems
that's when we saw change we passed net
neutrality regulations we changed
federal hate crimes policy what might it
mean to change the the templates the
structures by which we govern how and
how how we how we respond to climate
change so that's like imagining systems
so then finally love for ourselves this
the practices here are breathe push and
transition so um the midwife she doesn't
say breathe and then push the rest of
the way right she says breathe and then
push and then breathe again and then
push and then breathe again i think if
we're going to be in this fight you know
for ourselves for our children we can't
just keep pushing so that we get burnt
out so that we opt out what does it mean
to breathe
what does it mean to breathe in the
course of the day what does rest look
like what does it mean to let joy in
every night no matter how dark the day
is whether i'm coming back from a vigil
or a protest my son like says dance time
mommy and we dance i mean on election
night we danced right dancing um is for
us how we bring joy in and joy reminds
us of everything that is good and right
and worth fighting for right the future
that is worth fighting for so i think
that that making those practices loving
ourselves even as we're showing up to
the labor
is how we're going to continue to have
the energy and the stamina to keep
fighting between now and election day in
november but months and years beyond
that and honestly you guys this is what
this is the truth you know for the first
time in my life i i heard a voice in me
that was like i'm not strong enough like
i can't do it um i prefer non-existence
to this and it was frightening for me it
was
starting to appear in my mind and in my
heart um in the last three years after
this president took office that's how
dark it was for me and i thought
i need to find a different way like the
labor for justice has gone on long
before i was born it will continue long
after i die
what might it mean to make the labor for
justice an end in and of itself
and if we're showing up with love
through love if we're laboring with love
then we can last because if we're
laboring with love then the labor
becomes poorest and the labor is poorest
we can let joy in so this framework for
revolutionary love this orientation to
to show up with love is really a way to
like was primarily a way to save my own
life
and now more and more it's how we are we
are staying in the labor together
[Music]
that was fantastic wow i did not expect
a five-point
answer
question i thought it was just going to
be
love
she's like number one we do this number
two
okay we've got to move on to some
lightning round questions here we could
go on for another hour
no
no no no no we're gonna put put things
to the test right here right now when do
you feel the most connected with the
universe
when i'm holding
a sleeping baby in my arms
what do you want your final meal to be
anything that my mother makes
when was the last time you ugly cried
uh election night no uh when my friend
joyce died
who's the hardest person that you've
ever tried to love
bull beer uncle's killer describe your
soul in 10 words or less
infinite uh vibrant buoyant um
part of part of you what makes you laugh
out loud
my son
mommy
you are my rainbow flag of the universe
all the ways he tries to express his
love for me
it's a little too much what is your
biggest fear
uh that my children will die before me
what's one thing you know for sure
that i will die
what is your life's big question
how do i love
valerie corey thank you so much for
coming in here and challenging us and
and giving us the the five-point plan
for saving the planet i thought that was
pretty helpful yes nothing else
absolutely can't wait for your book to
come out i adore you both thank you so
much
[Music]
[Music]
reza
i revolutionarily love you
look i revolutionarily love you too do i
revolutionarily love trump
no
here's what i will say that was i
thought fascinating about this
conversation and it did give me a little
bit of clarity i have to be honest which
is that if what she is saying is that we
are engaged
in an existential conflict and i and i
believe that
and the other side is using the tools of
hate and fear and anger and racism
if her argument is
the most powerful weapon
to defeat that is love
okay i'm listening now now i'm listening
because what she's i think that's
exactly what she was saying yeah and now
i'm listening okay you know i think
before what i heard was just love them
you know
love them and that's the proper response
you know it's it's love them in order to
achieve maximum change which is their
defeat you know you can view love as
passive so easily that's like love is
passive it's soft it's uh it's not
empowered it's it's it's uh it's just
allowing people to walk all over you as
opposed to love as a as a positive
vital and
you know effective source for social
change yeah all right okay well i'm i'm
convinced okay good it worked uh
listeners how do you define love do you
think that love can be a force for
social change do you think we need a
revolutionary love
project to help us along i don't know
yeah tell us what you think you can find
us on socials reza aslan and rayne
wilson we are on twitter at
metamilkpodcast
how do you think we can love better
how can we change the world with love
yes and not in the sort of
you know hippy dippy dippy way but in
the real like love is a tool love is a
weapon it is powerful it can actually
work where other tools have failed
milkshakers as we always remind you uh
on our program if you rate and review us
on apple podcast or wherever you listen
to your fine podcasts and wait a minute
did you just come up with the perfect
name for fans of our show milkshakers
milkshakers i love it
we happen to have a milkshaker on the
program who did what we always say rate
review ask a question on apple podcasts
if we like the question we'll bring you
on and we'll ask you and we have a
milkshaker
with us
right now becky bortak from michigan hi
becky
hi reza hi rayne thank you so much for
having me on um so i have a big life's
question for you and my question is
about suffering no man i'm wondering
you're gonna bring us down aren't you oh
wow really bring things down here aren't
you couldn't it have been about kittens
or about empanadas
why are kittens so cute why are
empanadas so delicious fine becky hit us
here we go so suffering you know why
does it exist everyone experiences it we
we all live through it um do we bring it
on ourselves
is it a human problem is it a fate
chance you know what is it about
suffering and why is it out there
wow this is uh this just hits all the
notes doesn't it it's got some theology
in there some existentialism some
philosophy it it really does it it's
it's a cross-platform
question
and um and it doesn't matter if you're a
theist or an atheist
like why is there suffering in the
physical universe
and um
[Music]
yeah why does it have to be
so much why so much of it well look you
know the the sort of theological answer
that we've heard for you know
generations and generations is that uh
either that suffering is the result of
god you know testing you the bible has
this really beautiful verse where it
says you know god will never give you
more than you can handle so like
whatever you're suffering it's just
enough it's just like at the very edge
of what you can handle because god is is
testing you by the way
that's what a dick god is is that's true
right it's like what an [ __ ] it's
like i'm gonna push you right to your
absolute limit god would be an even
bigger dick if some theological people
say that that's not what suffering is
suffering is for
is for punishment and for the bad like
if you get cancer it's because you've
been a bad person that god is an even
bigger prick people had obviously
trouble with this notion that we're
describing the god is a dick theology
which is
uh
and so they invented the devil you know
if you're interested in the invention of
the devil i write all about it in my
previous book uh but uh
and so you know you put you put the the
the responsibility for suffering
uh on you know some kind of cosmic evil
right so that you're like well it's not
god's fault it's not my fault uh it's
you know the fault of of this demonic
being which also very unsatisfying rain
very unsatisfying
yeah an evil creature is like out of a
marvel comic book it doesn't
it's like thanos
thanos made me do it
um
as if there is a source from evil and it
always bothered me because if god is
all-powerful well
god could kill the devil at any time but
he i guess he chooses not to but i guess
where i always go with suffering
um is
uh number one for those atheists out
there uh we live in a physical universe
and uh suffering is part of that we're a
creature everything suffers uh the
buddha as the buddha says life is
suffering the joyful acquiescence in a
life of suffering a dandelion suffers
when someone steps on it you know a
kitty cat suffers when a kid throws a
rock at it you know a human being
suffers when they break a bone on a
swing set there's
levels and levels to suffering because
we have pain receptors
and we are
you know changeable beings and we'll be
dead at some point in time and we're
going to suffer along the way and we're
also have emotions that will suffer
besides our physical bodies but i always
frame this question and maybe i've said
this before on this show i can't
remember what would it be like
if there were no suffering what would
the what would the universe be like
because this is an often an argument
that's used to like show that there
couldn't possibly be a god because
there's all this suffering and if there
is an all-loving providence energy
a loving uh entity there wouldn't be so
much pain and suffering in the world and
it's like well okay so
let's pretend
that there is a
either there is a god or there isn't a
god but we're in a physical universe in
which there's no suffering right when
you're born the vagina opens up to be
the size
you know of a suitcase and you climb out
and there's no crying there's only
laughing and hugging the mom feels
nothing you know you never break a bone
right you never stub a toe or skin a
knee you know no one ever everyone only
dies at age like 100 and it's just
lights everyone knows they're going to
die at 100 and they're at peace with it
like that kind of unit that kind of
universe both from a you know a physics
standpoint and a biological standpoint
just makes zero sense and although also
from a theological standpoint it makes
zero sense because we realize us
especially all of us and we're a little
older than you becky um that suffering
uh is is is terrible and some people
have suffered far far far far far
greater than i ever have i'm a very
privileged sup minor sufferer
but our
our tremendous growth comes from
suffering and there has to be some kind
of
um
it's a some kind of spiritual arena
in this physical realm that involves
suffering the buddha was on to something
i mean that you can't have light without
darkness you wouldn't know what light is
if there wasn't darkness it's that kind
of
idea yeah no i agree i i know personally
like like you said rain i have
fortunately have not had any um extreme
suffering but the suffering i have has
you know helped me grow helped me become
a better person
and certainly been useful in my life um
and i think about the movie the matrix
and i remember one uh one um when they
talk about how the the machines had put
them in this dream state and they made
it a utopia and the people kept waking
up because it was too good and so this
is really interesting to think about
that and think about how we're sort of
built for suffering we sort of expect it
in our in our lives so i would agree
with you guys i do think that and and
i've said this before too that uh
as somebody who does believe that there
is evil in the world
but doesn't subscribe to some cosmic
source for that evil
just believes that evil is the result of
human actions you know the free will of
human beings um
you know i i think it's important that
we don't
um
we don't always sort of uh
try to come up with some kind of grand
cosmic idea for you know why i am
suffering you know why did what is god
trying to tell me by not you know
getting me that job
nothing nothing
you didn't get the job it sucks
cry for a little while
and then you know try again there is
also a kind of self-imposed suffering
right suffering comes in two different
ways suffering can come from like oh i
found out i have this terrible blood
disease and suffering can also come from
making the same mistakes over and over
again and i've certainly suffered a
great deal in my life from making a
series of bad decisions and then finding
myself making those same decisions over
and over and over again like what the
hell so
needing to learn from that suffering and
you know one could say well did
you know did god send that down reign
or or did you cause that i was like you
know i guess like reza says i don't know
i i don't know
i don't think i don't think god is like
a kind of a puppet master with each one
of us like little strings on each one of
us and he's got seven billion fingers
and there's seven billion human beings
and he's kind of like
uh orchestrating stuff but at the same
time like
i'm profoundly grateful i said
profoundly i'm profoundly grateful
um
for some of the suffering that i've
undergone and for the fact that there
has been some suffering in my life that
i've perpetrated and then had to kind of
mature my way out of yeah well thanks
becky this is uh you know
you brought us down that's fine
how we go from where we go from here but
just one last question who do you like
better
come on
well i was gonna say this so first of
all thank you both for answering my
question that was very helpful and i
really appreciate your thoughtfulness
and all you share with on your podcast
and um now to cheer myself up i'm gonna
go watch an episode of the office so oh
oh okay i i guess i'll
i'll just
sit here and ask god why it is that why
you just caused some suffering becky you
caused suffering in the heart of reza
aslan and for that i applaud you i don't
blame you i blame satan
satan spoke through becky to you reza
sorry rosa
all right becky
thank you very much thank you bo so
great to meet you bye bye
thank you again to our guest valerie
core
you can check out her work at
revolutionarylove.net and find her on
social at valerie and if you're so
inclined you can actually sign the
declaration of revolutionary love
it's at
revolutionarylove.net you'll be the
first to hear about the book and the
tools and the various ways to show up in
2020 and beyond i love you i love you
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold audio
mixed by joshua harris
original music is composed by jeff tang
it was additionally executive produced
by goal reese lucina and daryush
brazwella no thaft it was produced by
amy estroy and rebecca lehrer of the
mashup americans associate producers are
jocelyn gonzalez lindsey crowderwill
sarah pellegrini mary phillips sandy and
shelby sandlin
[Music]
i'm so grateful that my son
has the resilience when i when i don't
oh my god who's
rain wilson my phone's off but my
computer's ringing i'm sorry i'm sorry
we will cut all this out god damn it
really
that was so terrible
[Music]
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you